thank you very much it's a huge honor to
be here today I'm going to talk about
the information measure estimation and
how to have some magical procedure to
put your sample size from end to end I'm
sluggin without conducting any more
experiments it may look weird but later
hopefully you'll be convinced that it's
exactly a right description of our
results if the drones work with my lab
make our t1 card and Eng hon who is
still on the grind chingada buoy but
he's entering our lab is so good
actually we are not working for him and
my advisor sake wise man's temper who is
supposed to be giving this talk about
later we decided I'm gonna come first to
whet your appetite what's the question
we start with the simplest one suppose I
observe and samples ID from this crew
description p this supports as ass but I
don't know if sighs but I don't care
about that size I care about this tool
function or two class of functionals the
Shannon entropy of course very important
information theory and also a clear
about this function fi alpha defend to
be summation pH alpha any Alpha larger
than zero has got many interpretation
and also if you take the log is a normal
eyes a little bit it can be there in
entropy which human should we talk about
later so we're interested in this not
only because they are interesting in
practice on also because they exhibit
different levels of smoothness because
dysfunctional each have a sort of
announced most point as zero we want to
see how the estimation problems
difficulty varies according to level
smoothness so this question is very
fundamental and the is falling into
general realm of questions we are you
observe some samples from certain
distribution parameterize by certain
theta CRSP but you don't care pacita you
care about the functional so we need to
first go to us to this literature and
see what is known about that we start
with Shannon entropy Thanks accardi for
suggesting this picture then the most
ambitious question we can ask is that i
won't ask shannon entropy a given
samples what's optimal estimator however
I kudos that this literature you find
that in funny assemble theory there's no
consensus on what is optimal there are
many of them but unfortunately for this
problem is even worse for us and now of
them we can compute the optimal
estimator so basically we are really
screwed up in the final sample but
actually is well known you find a sample
theory if you access this vision I will
tell you in general is hopeless so it
has
at least observed 50 years ago that we
need to go beyond this we need to go to
asymptotics so ask question suppose what
have answer is the optimal estimator for
entropy when number of samples go to
infinity went by the problem size as is
fixed was optimal estimator this
probably also non trivial but now is
already classical is in the textbook we
define the quantity called empirical
entropy hpn where Pia is an empirical
distribution and the pia hat is simply
the empirical frequency of symbol I in
our other words is basically evaluates
entropy functional at the empirical
distribution it's basic plugging
approach can be shown to be maximum like
the estimator seems to be quite good I
can we can show to be quite good so
using the model of the empathic theory
we can show this it's as meter is really
good you know the inconsistency even a
constant so we can never improve even in
a constant in those in total sense so it
seems we can just go home because we can
show it's already extremely good even
these extensive efforts however there is
something meeting if you recall that we
have actually completely give up in the
final sample theory and we have got
something works really well in an
awesome products then what about i use
mo UN is finite if it is also very good
in some sense that we can also go home
because it is what we actually use
everyday be there is nothing to improve
however the same news is that in general
we're going to show for large class of
problems including all of us on we
discussed it can be a really bad idea
it's bad to the extent that if you use
this in practice probably your
application will complete atty virtue
but actually if you use the best one
it's going to converge and the cap is
really big so hopefully it's going to be
interesting and before talking about our
optimum schemes we need to discuss our
evaluation criteria we use the standard
status the decision theory framework
within otra mas o distribution which
forces us but even quantity Co the risk
function of supposed to ask me happy i
use f hat the risk function of F has it
different like this with even kinetic on
the maximum risk which basically is a
maximized risk function over all
possible distributions supported on as
elements that basically quantifies was a
worst-case performance of my estimator
and also the mannequin did he call the
minimax risk which is a maximally
you infamous over all possible
estimators in other words it's it
quantifies what's the minimum possible
worst-case performance I can achieve and
what I hope that the maximal risk of our
estimator is going to be at least close
to the minimax risk and then we should
be really good in this criterion we use
the following notation to quantify these
two constants sequence and now we are
going to start analyzing this so before
we start to construct the optimum
estimator what would we need to analyze
m.o.e but otherwise how can we know how
to improve that so we are to analyze out
to risk and even suggested we need to
analyze both bias and variance now you
cross the disc 1 1 the bias is defined
to be the functional miners expectation
of your estimator and the variance is
simply the definition of various what
about the Emory then we compute that we
compute knowledge importantly the
maximum risk family as media entropy and
they are to turn as we said squared bias
and variance and actually it is very
interesting to us because that's think
if you fix s but n go to infinity you
only be able to see the second term
because the first term vanishes at the
rate he and faster than 1 wherein
however if EDS may grow together
actually the first term we dominate
because the first time we will not
vanish if any smaller than s by second
term will easily vanish if n is larger
than log x squared so that will make a
conclusion in general for this problem
first of an as is the threshold for
consistency second thing that to the
pies escalates dominating and we need to
reduce bias or weekly with fear and
showing it's impossible to reduce pies
it's what we are going to do so but this
problem is also extremely fundamental in
statistics because whenever studies
estimation we want to either consider
the patterns of bias variance so let's
first review what we know about reducing
advice the general approaches well idea
you may come a demand which is taylor
series right I have hpn what about a
dual Taylor expansion of HPA around the
two point P computer certain
expectations and cancel certain term
correct certain terms it will try the
1950s and shown weapon is fear that
doesn't work it requires still as
samples bad idea for this and there's
also idea called jackknives
about this idea you correct that but you
plug in and prove dispersion into that p
that's in general idea Taylor series
expansion you expand that you corrupt
using your unknown estimate he radical
jackknife seems to reduce the biasing of
the in total sense however shown be open
instant not to work in this high
dimensional setting bad news the euro
idea called bootstrap be called
bootstrap ice reduction however it's
also resembling technique technique
really interesting is to this
methodology and we're based on the show
also does not work really disappointing
but we don't give up we also think the
idea could be a centimeter so what about
the way first designer prior and we
compute the payers response with this
conditional expectation under that prior
probably do we have a good of
frequentist properties we computed that
and also it does not work I student gave
up I think of an odd idea which is what
about that first use the th Light prior
to smooth distribution so call the lavas
smoothing the I plugins and should be
functional and we should also doesn't
work it's really bad actually there are
many more in the literature and not
exhausting all of them so it's really
frustrating we look at this question but
later there is a recent breakthrough by
valiant valiant show that the exact fit
transition for entropy estimation is as
over low guess it means that it is
suffice to take and much larger than a
solo guess to achieve consistent mission
now all the method we analyzed by some
of them at heart analyze cannot do it
but we look at slightly a teacher at the
air approach the essential have two
ideas one ideas based on linear program
is really quad yeah but has not yet be
shown to achieve the minimax risk in
other words in CS term is called
dependence on epsilon it means that
although I know and much matter does a
larger than a squirrel all gasp
excellent converts to zero but how fast
is not clear second thing achieves is
but only works for n not too big but we
want to make sure that whenever my own
asses I want it to be optimal and also
it's not clear how the approach can
achieve minimap stories for other
functional such as flv considered
because we also think as a general
mathematical theory wish they'd be able
to read ill very large class of
functions so we asked a very ambitious
question we will have to find a
systematic methodology to improve energy
stephen minimax rates were very wide
class of functions and we think it might
be easier actually then dealing with
only a single function we have to say
this problem is still wide open by later
we're going to discuss what we have done
so we are thinking about the reason why
Taylor series fails the region wide
bootstrapping jackknife fails we think
reason white fields is at first i'm
taylor series fails because taylor
series a local expansion idea we know
that Taylor series only quantifies a
functional in a local sense but our
question is a minimax estimation we take
the worst case over all possible cases
so it's very uniform criterion by you
use a use a local technique so in some
sense it's not really compatible with
the criteria the reason why bootstrap
and Jacqueline may feel is that they're
so generic ideas we proposed a really
hard minimax estimation problem highly
dependent on the functional however if
that works it means that some generic
idea of is now considering the
functional form f suddenly miraculously
succeed we think that too good to be
true so probably thing you stopped a
first principle consider simply setting
since we're going to reduce bias what
about I write down the expression bias
and see what looks like so I take a
simplest case X binomial random variable
which means as is to suppose I use
whatever estimator GX 2 s mean FG i read
a nap eyes it's not in position and we
found that suddenly we can draw two
conclusions so one conclusion is that
the only polynomial with older no more
than n can be estimated as a vice
because but 0 bytes as being the spice 0
for all p but that immediately implies F
P equals that guy but that guy is a
polynomial with older no more than
second thing that the bias actually
corresponds to a polynomial
approximation arrow which means that
probably if your item to reduce bias is
suffice to design a polynomial G such
that the Crocs me that FP really well
this idea actually not proposed by us in
2003 and police they proposed to try to
solve this problem suppose try to
minimize this the suprima of a bias g
and try to find the a polynomial g try
to find the coefficient g such you can
minimize that because that's essentially
minima bias you can ever have and
unfortunately it doesn't work it's very
disappointing with you this idea is so
good how can this no work
but later we thought that there is a
simple reason explaining why doesn't
work because to remember at the
beginning we said hey o'clock and told
us as n go to infinity emma is really
good it means i will n go to infinity
whatever estimator you give me it has to
be similar to emily with similar to plug
in however with that scheme as n goes
infinity give me something similar to
emily it is not very clear as well
actually we can show is far from it so
basically as simple as a violet is
already existing tech conclusions in the
empathic statistics o stands 92 fail but
then we think the idea is still very
good because it clearly captures what
what is a bias and pest polynomial
Proclamation has been introduced by a
home and it's basically the polynomial
that minimize the maximal deviation
function and Abed polynomial here's our
approach for all the functionals we
consider with the decomposed the region
into two for each and pupae frequency p
a hat AP ahead is smaller than logo ran
with the hell are you operating in an
honest mood switching because the
function we consider p log p or PhD
alpha a zero probably is not
differentiable or is not even times
differentiable we thinks bad and we
replace that functional we simply
through that functional way I think this
function too bad i replace that by the
polynomial so that functional tester
disappear it's a we replaced with a
polynomial with low order log n then we
apply unbiased estimate of that
polynomial because as we discussed
before any polynomial which order no
more than n can be estimated with a
price we ask me that for that part
smooth is easy we sink the plug-in
actually but turns out you still need to
certain correction which is something we
are still trying to understand now a
simple methodology we apply to any
function we considered and turns out to
achieve and back maximum risk the best
results then but you may ask me the
forum question I understand that there
you need to start a threshold because
you're seeing your functional the
problem of the bus mainly contributed by
the pond near zero but why it's a
cut-off logon / n I understand you need
to do approximation but we're by
approximation Logan this stuff but you
need to understand this
to do it it is paper by sergey bernstein
in 1938 best approximation certain
function we need to use these hardcore
mathematics to finally solve this here
is time to acknowledge that these ideas
really inspired by pioneers in the field
for be the plan the pioneers paper by
Lapsley nemirovsky in spoken in 1999 who
used a trigonometric polynomial
approximation to deal with non
parametric settings then did a very
interest paper by Tony Tyler Chloe 11
that there with our norm estimation and
realize that it's going to be really
nice important to replace trigonometric
polynomial by polymer polynomial and
later after with amita work we realized
he home and student penguin independent
realized idea based upon him
approximation to entry problem and
divide a really nice technique the lower
bound which he has just explained but
here's something more to be said what
with the show that's also something that
this methodology essentially has very
deep root in the statistic methodology
and actually it's a duality with
shrinkage and here many experts done
nonparametric estimation in short it
means that the shrinkage is designed to
reduce the various and our a method of
least you can to reduce the bytes so
whenever you have something in practice
either on to reduce bias you all want to
reduce various now you have post
methodologies now here are some
mathematical results we don't have time
to discuss too many details so f alpha
remembers this and here is l to r is
emily for all class of functional vb
considers hopefully still remember the
first one this entropy we showed before
there are two terms whenever there are
two terms the first term corresponds to
a squared vice second term corresponds
to the virus and we can see that they
are we actually obtained both upper
lower bounds of this so it's an exact
characterization maximal rates of m.o.e
and you can use the season when the
alpha is larger than one actually the
rig does not depend s so basic means
really easy to estimate but now we ask
you what's the minimax rich how does
minimax improve orem oh yeah by how much
we think sis so you can just see that
for the maximal retire ye usually only
by this dominating you pick out the
dough me confirm and you replace that
and we ascend ham slogan you replace
that every n Times log on you replace
that Angus n Times log and review please
Bambi's and time Logan here you cannot
do because of our brains are the best
even as this one so you can never do
anything there's already the best but
actually after you take the log if you
ask Miss really entropy you still need
to replace any s times longer so here's
our methodology we think we've
discovered very interesting phenomenon
we call effective sample size
enlargement it means that for very large
class of problems the performance of the
minimax read-option estimator with n
samples essentially that is mo v's
intense log and sample is precisely a
logarithmic enlargement we also test
they'll talk about these things in
assemble complexity perspective which is
more common in CS community for entropy
Amelia cheese s and the optimal s or log
s first shown by valiant valiant FL fuh
is as 1 over alpha which actually think
alpha is less than 1 so as well what
Elvis actually super paulino super
linear really hard to do and here what
you actually do is to slightly improve
that you have low crizzly factor of a
larger than when everything does not
depend on s so it's actually a lossy
compression of our channel results okay
then we will have to find more bubble
time to be estimated ticket probably is
something that people want to use in
practice first of all we analyze we
emphasize just one realization of
general methodology whose generality
will still discuss later people we found
the problem very fast and he has very
difficult and we also achieve the
minimax rates and we also need to
emphasize agnostic to the knowledge of s
so it's interesting one may think that
you need to first known a lot knowledge
of s to ask me entropy but actually show
it's not necessary so basic but
estimating knowledge they ask me a
knowledge of s the support says as even
show is a very difficult question but
actually for the entropy estimation is
easy fixed we do need to do that
difficult part and also easily
implementable Rico that's the only
non-trivial computation we're going to
do is a pipette polynomial approximation
is order log in which grows really
slowly we use the following a nice
software developed by nick treverton
guru payouts for university then it
computes a 500 order visit half a second
and the empirical performance without
poor phone with every available entropy
estimator these are video a lot in the
literature and our code to be released
this week but now you can send the email
we can send you the code you can play
busy but however after we show this to
some study stations we usually get many
constructive criticism which we really
appreciate but this is a we may not use
this myth unless you prove its adaptive
and we own what does it mean what do you
mean by rubios adaptive let me give you
this example so what you have shown what
you have shown to me is that the maximum
risk of your estimator it's nearly the
same of the minimax risk of overall
estimators but i do really think you
take the worst case overall peep doesn't
make any sense why usually you say oh
their applications whereas is large
however usually one case that is large
is in language modeling let's consider
Chinese language chinese-language
already known that the available
characters at most at least 80 k really
large number however if you consider an
author's work to they artists audio
distribution on their characters really
like worst case over all possible
distortions support a nadie que no so
most of frequently use a symbol at most
a 5k so busy you actually naturally know
something the distortion his uh his
title but actually you do know exactly
so there's a water by to the following
suppose I already know a a priori my
entropy is upper bounded by H which is a
small number which is much much smaller
than Lopez already know it and what I
want is that you construct me an
estimator such that your maximum risk
search over this set which is a set of
distributions supporting our ass
elements and also whose entropy is very
small I want the worst case over that
set to be similar to the minimax with
over as I said which means that suppose
I they know the piece in that said I
designed the best estimator so basically
i want as made of doing that but here
when the Beast has a question but I
don't know this H right in general I may
have something but I don't know exactly
probably I took the worst case that h is
duel against but they ask the question
can estimator satisfy all the
requirements all of these for all s and
all age without knowing any s with on
ouh is it really possible we found this
really big challenge because the means
that it's really not clear whether we
can really do it why we like challenges
so we showed it is adaptive
so recently we capitalized the
completely is the minimax wrist of
estimation of entropy if you take a su
prima over jet set for any age and we
show that they are essentially any set
in any region and just up to a universal
constant and then the first part is very
similar to what we had before the second
part is roughly set aside it but it's
nicely see the corollary they did
slightly confusing and hard to interpret
and you'd agree what's up what's the
corollary we implies that if epsilon is
at least a cholo gas which might be very
small remember that we are considering
on case at the H is very very small
compared to low gas that it requires and
as 1 minus epsilon H over H samples to
achieve the root mean square error
absolute let's consider suppose because
H over log s is very small I take H will
be a constant favor for example epsilon
also a constant what is 1 minus epsilon
where h is 1 minus beta so basically
here the number of samples i need is no
longer a logarithmic improvement over s
it's as 1 minus delta which is a very
very small so basically the means that
if i give you a prior knowledge of the
entropy h upper bound by small H it
really helps a lot but then you may
wonder what a time of evening probably
MOU still requires s actually it's not
the MOU still requires slightly more
than that still a slightly log
reasonable factor so you see all really
that in this case if i give you the
upper bounds that's to entropy is no
more than H even m.o.e can be easily
sublinear because this time stop linear
it's just a logarithmic factor so the
immediately phase out here still the law
n to n Times log of a performer /
phenomena still full refund is very
intriguing because this is already no
longer the question we investigate
before but this channel phenomen still
holds true which is really hard to
understand but we found that so we
probably rethink this kind of the
nominees can be more popular and more
generous and then then we'll be
investigating however then we discuss
all of this is always on to
mathematicians they also read some
constructive criticism they feel that
all kind of cool however that some isn't
really general I want
yes is that what does general mean I
means that all the functional you can't
have considered you have one
discontinuous or non-differential points
only one point one point I understand
your methodology romantic allure seems
to say that you cover the one point by
interval but one tea interval for sure i
know that can give me something it's not
differential not at the one point then
we consider this example l1 distance
this l1 distance the mountain dew point
is a whole line because you think of
this as a PI via the function as to why
the point that is not differentiable
oblong XE goes to Y then here also need
to mention recent breakthrough by
valiant valiant this shows that optimal
scaling is as overall gas which means
that if you sample n times from P sample
n times 1 q the number of symbols needed
to 2's me this guy is a solo gas however
we are still stop small catch which is
only shown to be optimal what is known
not really because ass then what we want
something more what about a slightly
larger I won't steal this to be optimal
but this we apply our general
methodology and we solved it we show
that minimax l2 reads its ass over and
Logan where mu is a sore exactly and
still be in large tool and hem slogan
and we show that the construction young
VV cannot achieve this winning / assess
so basically it's not because they
didn't analyze is because this by
definition in construction cannot really
do it but this is very complicated
because currently the non-smooth region
is no longer one point is no it's not
very clear that you use one while
interval to cover it but but but how to
cover line you may think Rob I use small
square I cover HD at they really
boundary cover square coverages or I use
a band to cover this whole line or use
some other shape we don't have time to
discuss our results we need to share
with you some venues the venues that you
may think oh we still use ideal best
paulino approximation in 2d is not
unique until now there is no occasion
agar is to compute it and also they've
been used to think oh I don't need a
really bad polynomial I just need a
polynomial whose approximation property
is quite good it's also bad news I can
give you some polynomial or choose best
porno
Paulino approximation read but cannot be
used and also all the announcements
region construction idea in this or fail
it's very disappointing so the solution
you might get a hint for our paper or
wait for our soon-to-be finish the paper
and the better I don't have time but I
want to show you one example so some
people also ask us that we don't really
care a lot with me improvement it seems
the cooling theory but it doesn't really
make any sense in practice we want to
show you actually it's not the case
because I didn't talk about the
constants we take the sequence n is 2 x
over log s because we know the entropy
estimation x over log s is the threshold
is a red scaling we take this as equally
sampled from 10 to 2 207 for each and a
sample 20 times from a uniform
distribution they will give a sense
little bit s over N so actually it means
really big means you really understand
provision has therapy compared to end
here the performances that's all I'm
going to show you can see that s over n
is the tool over it's really big Daniel
II really really bad here at the entropy
here at this one is roughly 14 Amelia
achieves mean square error 4.5 hours is
essentially zero so there's another
application in machine learning that I
cannot talk about which also significant
band-aid for the improvement in learning
tree graphical models and also we also
didn't have talked about many other more
stuff example but didn't say how analyze
the pious IML ye which also was not
known before and we need to connect this
with another field approximation theory
study over 100 years is the white
bootstrap jackknife fail and the
multiverse settings nonparametric citing
now I the settings and all who applies
this some hand side so purpose we're
gonna skip is dere sound related work
really nice inspiring pioneers that we
suggest any everyone to read and this
also later in actually going to talk
about this work that is some of our work
first why is among work second ones
annalise.m you this is an application
system divergence it's not that
estimation they showed the original
doesn't work this gives the general
methodology of analyzing taylor series
bootstrap and jackknife when these these
answers one question that will check
once we discussed on how to analyze the
gap of Jensen's inequality thank you
very much
you